Mélina bonjour notre envoyé spécial à
carquive avec notre équipe un mot de la
situation là où vous trouvez dans la
foulée de ces frappe ruses
écoutez Elisabeth après 48 heures de
frappe intensive et coordonnées le pays
fait son maximum pour penser ses plaies
le plus rapidement possible ce qui nous
marque avec les équipes sur le terrain
depuis le début de cette guerre c'est la
véritable résilience de cette population
alors je suis consciente que c'est un
mot très galvaudé mais c'est très
difficile de trouver un autre
qualificatif quand on discute avec la
population locale ce que vous voyez
derrière moi cette immense panneau qui
dit ralkif ville de héros ce n'est pas
seulement de la propagande ce n'est pas
seulement une posture c'est la réalité
sur le terrain lorsqu'on discute avec
avec les gens nous parlions avec un
couple juste à l'instant sur cette place
à Khalif dont la jeune femme Oxana nous
expliquait qu'elle avait quitté la ville
qui a été bombardée pendant très
longtemps au début de la guerre pendant
plus de trois mois qui est parti en
Pologne et qui vient juste de revenir il
y a à peine trois jours qui affiché un
énorme sourire sur le visage elle est
revenue au moment où il y a eu ses
frappes coordonnées dans le pays on lui
demandait mais comment ça se fait que
vous vous avez ce grand sourire c'est
quand même assez difficile ce qui vous
arrive elle dit oui mais on est habitué
et puis surtout il y a rien un petit peu
et bien qui peut égaler ce sentiment
incroyable de revenir à la maison de
revenir chez nous et c'est vraiment ce
qui nous frappe c'est aussi la rapidité
avec laquelle les les autorités
reviennent essaient de se relever de ses
attaques vous parliez tout à l'heure de
coupure de courant ça a été le cas elle
vive par exemple dans l'ouest du pays où
la ville a connu jusqu'à 80 % de
blackout et bien aujourd'hui tout est
rétabli au courant électricité gaz donc
c'est vraiment il y a une rapidité avec
laquelle les autorités et bien remettre
en place la ville pour essayer de
retrouver un semblant de de normalité et
pour autant les sirènes continuent de
sonner de manière sporadique un peu
partout dans le pays et pour cause vous
avez parlé de ces frappes qui ont fait
cette mort dans l'Est dans le dombasme
nous trouvions il y a encore deux jours
il y a eu également cette frappes dans
le sud du pays asapolija et puis
également une frappe non loin de cette
centrale nucléaire qui a qui a
interrompu le courant qui a entraîné une
alimentation une coupure de
l'alimentation électrique sur cette
centrale nucléaire qui vous le savez et
la cause de préoccupation aussi bien de
l'Ukraine que de la communauté
internationale merci beaucoup Mélina
Huet en direct de car qui va vendre de
marquer une courte pause les Ukrainiens
qui ont le sourire aussi